to start I think we met at an airport
probably meant a little bit more to me
than it did to you at the time I was I
was eight and uh and you were my you
were and are my biggest were my biggest
crush in the whole world I was so in
love with you it was like in a like like
a crazy Obsession after Charlie's Angels
and I I came up to you to talk to you
and I just completely froze and then um
you were so sweet and you said oh thank
you so much and then you went onto the
plane and I said hey mom um would you
mind if I sat with Drew and and she said
no net I think she's in first class and
and you were with one of the guys from
The Strokes and I was like I think I
could take that guy yeah
you look like a stroke now
I was waiting my time Brittany I was
obsessed with you on White Lotus I have
to bring it up season one
foreign
I I just thought that your acting was so
incredible it's like you and Sydney
Sweeney played off each other so well
what's it like being in the White Lotus
franchise oh my gosh I didn't know that
it was going to be what it was when we
were filming it so it was a really
exciting Challenge and very complex
character I think she turned a lot of
people on and off uh like my mom was
like I'm disgusted by what she did I was
like or like people like I'm getting
like I don't know stuff at the pharmacy
and the girl comes and tells me like oh
your character is so annoying here are
your antibiotics I'm like thank you
um so Matt in the intro I talked about
um how you're a terrible driver is it
true that you almost ran over Jennifer
Connelly the beautiful actress yeah not
on purpose you know they actually asked
can you drive I said yeah I can drive
I've never been behind the wheel of a
car and then I got on set and on my
first like you know the first shot I'm
saying goodbye to my mom Jennifer
Connell to pay my mom and she's walking
behind the car and I think it's in drive
but it's in reverse and it goes she
jumps out of the way and I'm like oh God
I'm so sorry and then I'm but and then
the director comes to the car and he's
like you almost just killed a National
Treasure
which is things to watch what see do
listen
um purchase to better your life do you
guys have a suggestion each one each
that you could give for the Weekender
my uh my sweet sister-in-law got me a
Vitamix and I love it so much you can
make hummus you can make smoothies you
can make soups like I don't know it's
just me I was like wow I didn't know
things could be Blended so nicely that
I've been listening to this album by Tom
Waits from the 70s called closing time
which is such a great album
okay
in summation what the heck is this show
the consultant and why are we all going
to be talking about it oh well there we
go I noticed that when I was doing this
show it started to infiltrate my dreams
because there's something kind of
subconscious subconsciously
destabilizing about the entire thing and
confronting and and uh it's really
really funny but then I watched the show
and suddenly I was having the dreams
again too I think there's just something
about the show that it just permeates
goes right into like this deep part of
you that's a great description Brittany
what do you want people to know about
the show I think that the show uh in I
mean it's an extreme version of of kind
of having a bad boss right in the
lengths that people are willing to go to
to excel in their career
and as much as it's a fever dream it's
also very funny and extremely
entertaining Brittany and Nat thank you
so much for coming by
[Applause]
everyone are available to stream now on
Prime video and we have an extra special
news story after the break and let's
just say it's kind of delicious you'll
love it we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]